hello guys and welcome to another video
in this video we're going to be
discussing the potential spider-man 4
with toby mcguire now before we get into
this video there is going to be spoilers
for spider-man no way home so if you
haven't seen that film already then
please click off this video now so today
on twitter people have been campaigning
for spider-man 4 in trending on twitter
everyone's been tweeting about it so i
thought i'll keep you guys up to date
and let you know what's happening so
with no way home marvel and sony has
delivered some of the biggest moments in
any comic book movie ever and because of
this 2022 kicks off a new fan campaign
around another spider-man movie while
toby mcguire and andrew garfield were at
the center of rumors for month after
their past villains were confirmed for
spider-man no way home seen the two
former spider-man on screen was
something that helped make no way home
hit the adventure of a lifetime tom
holland has shared how incredible it was
to work with both of the former
spider-man and excitingly fans of crying
out to see more of the spider-mans in
the future rumors were already pointing
to sony being interested in bringing
garfield back to make the amazing
spider-man 3 which comes after the fact
that fans have cried for this movie to
be made following no way home success
over the past few weeks spider-man fans
have taken to twitter to plan a
widespread promotion on january the 5th
for a desired spider-man 4 starring toby
mcguire the first of these messages came
from twitter user real underscore earth
underscore 9811 pushing fans to spread
the word about making a movie trend
along with an image of toby maguire's
spider-man the same user also tweeted an
idea of what turbulent spider-man 4
could look like it reads make a logan
style spider-man movie with maguire
don't tie it in with any cinematic
universe whatsoever just do a rough
beautiful emotional tale about an older
spidey now since then there have been
plenty of other tweets with people using
this hashtag to get a trend in which it
has been successful at doing so but the
real question is will spider-man 4
really happen now i think it's actually
entirely possible now fans were
responsible for zack snyder's justice
league to be made by using that hashtag
so i think a similar situation to that
can actually happen for spider-man 4 so
if you want to see this film just keep
tweeting that hashtag now there's
actually some rumors which i made a
video about before about spider-man 4
being in development now or at least
it's being spoken about so if you do
want to watch the video about the room
at toby maguire spider-man 4 and i will
link that in the end screen that out of
the way that comes to the conclusion of
this video so please like and subscribe
if you haven't already and also to turn
notifications on to show your support
thanks for watching guys